so first of all congratulations on this
show who
encouraged you to join the show
we honestly feel like it was just led by
the universe like spirit led it chased
us it came to us yeah we were meant to
do it and
we actually got scouted from a youtube
video yeah
no wait what were you doing in the
youtube video we were regularly charging
our food we were doing like our psychic
stuff we had our own psychic sisters
youtube channel and we were teaching
people how to manifest how to wreck it
charge their food and
kind of just how we are as moms so it
gave the viewers like a glimpse of
us and a casting director got a hold of
it and then
found found her for a reading and then
yeah
she had to she had to hire me to give
her a reading in order to get
in touch with me
that's such a great story so have you
guys
always had this close relationship since
birth or is this something that's kind
of gradually taken time to
form instead oh yeah
since birth i mean you know growing up
we we had to be each other's rocks
you know we we didn't really have a
solid you know
uh family unit yeah family unit to look
up to we just had each other
and we got each other through the
hardest times of our lives
you know we just did everything together
that's so nice to have someone that you
can lean on like that that you can trust
wholeheartedly like the older i get the
more you realize there's not many people
like that in your life so it's so nice
and you can have that
so i understand that you both got
married at the same time you both got
pregnant at the same time
was that nice being able to share those
big moments in your lives together
absolutely it was amazing we got to
especially being pregnant because i
would call her and say oh my gosh like
i'm having a symptom and she said don't
worry i'm having the same one
so and what's funny is this was not
planned we did not plan to be married at
the same time we did not plan to get
printed at the same time
our lives have always been parallel like
literally i think it's because
we're so in sync it's like we just kind
of create the same paths
by being so in sync if that makes sense
yeah no i actually
just assumed you guys maybe had planned
that so it's so interesting to hear that
that just it just happened
mm-hmm and you know and i want more kids
i don't want to go through pregnancy
without her so i'm like we need to find
her a man
we need to get her you know i'm bored so
that way we can get pregnant
i don't plan we don't plan so i know
that's the thing you gotta keep that
parallel streak going so yeah
i gotta i gotta find me a man apparently
okay so here's the thing so i also
uh i understood that you both got
divorced at the same time too right
yeah did either of you feel bad or
responsible for
the relationship ending with the other
person
at the time i don't think that's it i
think we're naive to it
this honestly yeah i actually feel like
this show and
our filming process and this journey is
actually us
well you okay starting to see
the effects that it created and starting
to see
it's the pattern the pattern you know i
don't think for me
personally it didn't take until me
getting into my new relationship
um and and really wanting it to work to
say wait a minute why did my other
relationships fail
and it opened my eyes and i think that's
when we discovered that okay we've got a
problem
because just know we've done it to each
other this is a two-way street here yeah
exactly i know
so that's fun like okay wait a minute
we've gotta you know do something
different
and the glamorous came at a time where
we were discovering that so they got to
capture
the real rawness of like how we were
experiencing how do we uncode
that codependent
oh that's interesting especially you
know that's not something that you plan
to really kind of
you know really delve into so when it
comes to this season is that what people
are gonna
can expect to see from you guys just
really understanding how close
and the pros and cons of your
relationship is yes that's
exactly what the viewers are gonna see
they're gonna see the journey of okay
our closeness is creating relationship
issues
yeah what do we do but you're also going
to see the relationship issues that it
creates does that make sense you're
going to see
i think i think the viewers get to see
all parts of a sister bond
not just the fun parts you know because
everything has to have a balance right
there are some challenging parts
to being this close right and we're
gonna you know we are gonna
show the viewers some of those
challenging parts
now do you guys have a special code that
you use for each other or the other one
has to drop absolutely everything to
support the other one
yeah we do right
so before we leave like if i know i'm
going to be within a 30
mile radius i'll say you better be rush
ready
and so what happens like there's been
times where she's needed me or i needed
her
and we just say the code word rush and
i've been on a date
and she texts me the code word and i
stopped the date and left within seconds
yeah
oh because i was just going to ask what
is the most inopportune time that a code
word's been
signaled and you would say being on a
date i was on a date
and no ifs ands or buts i gotta go i
i mean i mean i didn't care about the
date it was
my sister needs me yeah yeah i'm rushing
to her
instantly and i'm a good restaurant yeah
she's she is a really good restaurant i
have a better recipe than her she is
sometimes i get annoyed like dang it
like i'm in the middle of something yeah
i rushed to you you rushed me yeah you
guys i love your relationship like
every relationship has pros and cons but
you guys i can just feel it you're so
close you're so loyal to each other
um how much do your kids get along oh
they're best friends
best friends you know there's times
where i feel guilty only having a single
child
but then i always remember he does have
brothers and sisters maybe not like well
actually technically by blood
because they have the same mom dna wise
so yeah he has
he does have siblings in a way right he
has her kids
yeah and they experience all of their
childhood like those big
events in their childhood you know
holidays birthdays they experience those
memories together
so they get to grow up just having like
those special moments with each other
yeah we always want to raise our kids
you know they do have two moms
now do you guys feel physically sick
when you're apart
we do and we're we do and it's been a
challenge
you know we've died too i think yeah
it's good we get anxiety
i think that's not looking back just all
of the times that we've really felt
those
i would say just just sporadic physical
like
physically moments um a lot of it is
triggered by anxiety like oh my god mike
is my sister she's not rush ready she's
not she's
she's far away because we're so used to
being together
no there's been times i've sat in cars
while she's in meetings
for 12 hours because she doesn't want me
away from her
oh those are not good times by the way
well just to wrap things up i have two
sisters i think i'm close with them
clearly i'm not as close as you guys are
what advice would you give me to be
quote clinically obsessed with my
sisters
[Laughter]
i would say share the toilet no
don't do that or how to wash your hands
yeah um honestly if you want to be
clinically obsessed
you need to be the ultimate ride or die
you need to be so loyal where no man
comes in the way
no friend comes in the way no no habit
no
hobby nothing she's your number one
rider guy that is amazing advice you
guys this is such a fun interview thank
you so much and congrats on the show no
you guys are like honestly i get why
you're on tv